und vielleicht dass auch ein appell an
der lauterbacher ohne dass er sofort
hochgeht
lauterbach ist geologe und fachmann er
ist aber auch politiker und er weiß das
ist auch die andere seite der medaille
gibt und es ist alles richtig und ich
finde auch dass deutschland richtig gut
durch die krise kommen nur wir dürfen
keine angst macherey in deutschland
verbreiten auch keine keinen keinen
alarmismus
ich glaube dass deutschland weiß und die
menschen auch dass wir verantwortung
übernehmen müssen wenn aber
beispielsweise abends nur die
infektionszahlen veröffentlicht werden
ist das schwierig sondern die müssen in
zusammenhang gesetzt werden also was ich
damit sagen will ist ich erwarte am
dienstag klare vorgaben wegen mir auch
klare vorgaben für die frage wie ist das
mit privaten feiern weil wir genau
wissen bei privaten feiern gibt es die
probleme übrigens nicht draußen
deswegen müssen weihnachtsmärkte und so
weiter stattfinden da kann man auch
gerne hart sein bei den privaten sachen
aber ich möchte nicht dass dieses land
in angst versetzt wird sondern dass die
eigenverantwortung des einzelnen
gestärkt wird unter den chor unter
bedingungen die wir kennen
wir haben jetzt die sorgen der
wirtschaft gehört die kanzlerin spricht
trotzdem davon die zügel wieder
anzuziehen würden sie jeder beipflichten
und sagen wir brauchen möglicherweise
der obergrenze bundesweit für
familienfeiern beispielsweise oder einem
matten pflicht im freien
ja auf jeden fall zunächst mal zur
korrektur ich bin kein theologe
wenn man so ein epidemiologe aber
nichtsdestotrotz also ich glaube dass
man vorsichtig sein muss dass man
denjenigen die jetzt warnen und konkrete
vorschläge machen was zu tun ist in den
nächsten wochen dass man den alarmismus
unterstellt